let's talk now about George papadopolis
the big news yesterday was that two
Trump campaign staffers were arrested
indicted charged with really serious
crimes Paul Manafort and Rick gates that
made the biggest headlines but we also
learned yesterday that this other guy
named George papadopolis
was not only indicted but had already
pleaded guilty earlier this month now
why is that huge it connects Donald
Trump directly to the Russia scandal
through Carter Page wait David hold on
you got a backup Carter page George
papadopolis what are you talking about
let's take it in pieces number one fewer
headlines but George papadopolis pled
guilty for lying to the FBI about his
contacts with Russia specifically okay
Trump fists are saying well the meetings
and the things that George papadopolis
did weren't illegal only the line was
well we don't know that right I mean
first of all he may only have been
charged with the lying because he agreed
to cooperate secondly if the meetings
were no big deal why would he lie about
them in the first place to protect
others protect himself it's not really
clear doesn't make sense you would lie
if there was no particular reason to lie
and lastly he's cooperating and taking
others down so the idea that we can
glean whether or not illegal activity
took place other than the lying this is
a proactive cooperator what that means
is by the way legal experts have written
that the fact that Papadopoulos was a
pro active collaborator suggests that
either he was wearing a wire after his
initial July July arrest or that he was
volunteering to have all of his
communications surveilled which means
that this is probably just a very small
piece of the bigger picture here and
that's exactly what we've heard actually
from Justice Department officials so we
this is part of a bigger investigation
and we're gonna learn about that so
we've got Papadopoulos Papadopoulos has
a contact that's referred to as the
professor and this reads like a spy
novel right the professor became
interested in talking to george
papadapolis after it became known that
Papadopoulos was working for the Trump
campaign so that is a direct connection
to the campaign and there's a sort of
necessary interlude here the Trump
campaign continues to pretend
as Sarah Huckabee Sanders did during
yesterday's press briefing that this
george papadapolis guy was merely you
know he was basically a waiter he was
running and getting coffee you hear
sarah huckabee sanders saying he was a
volunteer it's nonsense right they make
it seem as though Papadopoulos was
involved in nothing important one of
hundreds or maybe thousands of random
people who just showed up to help but we
have the information trump referred to
this guy as a top foreign policy adviser
there's a picture which we have for our
audience of george papadapolis sitting
there two seats over from jeff Sessions
at the same table with Donald Trump and
other top advisors that is a high-level
strategy session and we have the audio
of Trump naming him an important advisor
but here's the real kicker here's where
it gets fascinating
Carter page Carter page admitted last
night when speaking to Chris Hayes on
MSNBC and it appears as though Carter
page is not being advised by any lawyer
because why he would even show up and do
this interview I couldn't tell you
Carter page admitted yesterday so not
only being in touch with George
papadopolis but to being in touch with
George papadopolis about Russia and
there is no doubt about Carter pages
connection to both Russia and Donald
Trump and he admitted on national
television yesterday that yeah he was in
touch with Papadopoulos about Russia
take a look were you guys on email
chains together you and Papadopoulos
look I there's a lot of emails all over
the place when you're in were you an
email chains of Papadopoulos probably a
few yeah were you an email chains with
him about Russia it may have come up
from time to time yeah there's nothing
nothing major yeah nothing major it was
enough for him to lie to federal
investigators about and then plead
guilty to that he was having an
intermediary come to him and saying you
should come to London and talk to
someone who's got Hillary Clinton's
emails yeah nothing major
except that yeah I was in touch about
Russia with a guy whose lies about
Russia have gotten him not only arrested
and indicted but already to plead guilty
once Carter page is involved the
plausible deniability for the top tier
of trumps campaign
including Trump himself evaporates
completely if page is even willing to
say this or do this interview there's a
couple possibilities one is and I
believe he said that he's not being
actively represented by any attorney and
that shows because this is a crazy
interview to do but it also might
indicate that he's cooperating because
if he is so willing let's assume for a
second he's smart and I don't know if
Carter Page is smart if he's smart and
he's thinking through does it really
make sense to go on national TV and say
these things it's because he's already
cooperating and he is being used to go
further and further up the chain here we
don't know the answer but we now have
absolute definitive connection between
Papadopoulos and Trump to Russia through
Carter page at minimum if not through
more connections that are forthcoming
send me your thoughts it's all imploding
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show today's
program is made possible in part by Blue
Sky binary have you heard of blockchain
blockchains the new trend in technology
and on the Internet and too many people
are not aware of both the power and the
risks of blockchain technology some
people think it's too complicated it's
too difficult to get into so people stay
away and they miss out on the
opportunity to really know about the
opportunities that blockchain presents
but it doesn't have to be this way and
the solution is the blue sky binary
blockchain academy blue sky binary is a
leading financial education and
technology company and they're turning
their attention to blockchain they've
launched their blockchain academy to
complement their other successful
training programs and they've created a
blockchain education course for
beginners and active crypto users alike
and in this score a course students will
be taken through a series of topics
which ultimately will deliver a solid
understanding of how blockchain works
and help the student realize the current
and potential future uses of block tank
blockchain technology we've talked about
some of these on the bonus show and on
the program and the course includes
video on-demand online tests access to a
community of traders and blockchain
enthusiasts who exchange knowledge and
experiences and you can read
Sterne now to get a three day free trial
that includes access to the first module
of the course for you to evaluate the
overall quality of the program and
afterwards it's forty nine and
ninety-nine a month you can stop and
resume at any point checkout blueSky
binary.com slash david to sign up today